(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
Today's conversation
we're gonna be talking
about athlete life, stigma,
body image and wellness
with Victoria Garrick.
And I'm really excited
about this conversation.
I've been excited and looking forward
to hosting her for quite a while
just because of who she
is, the influence she has
and the way that she really
brings her whole self
and talks to in so many authentic ways,
in so many spaces and heads,
really I think transforms
aspects of culture
especially among athletes.
So by way of introduction
did want to go ahead
and give you all a feel
for who Victoria is.
She is a former Division
I volleyball player,
a TED talk speaker,
and a mental health and
body image advocate.
She was a four year starter at USC,
won a Pac-12 championship with
her team while she was there.
And impressively finished
her career with the top five
most digs in program history.
In 2017, she also gave a TED talk
entitled The Hidden Opponent,
where she described her battles
and overcoming of depression and anxiety.
And that talk itself has been
viewed over 380,000 times.
So really speaking to the
timeliness of that talk
and her influence.
She has a really large
social media following
which I mentioned with
over 1 million followers
across social media platforms.
She has a weekly podcast called Real Pod,
and also started a nonprofit
called The Hidden Opponent
where she through that
foundation has been traveling
around the country really
talked about mental health
conversations and ways to de-stigmatize
and really increase awareness.
So I'm honored, thrilled,
and grateful to welcome
Victoria Garrick to the Addy Hour..
Thanks so much for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it
and excited to chat with you today.
- Excellent. I'm excited as well.
And I will say, I mean I've
alluded to this already
but you do have a lot of
energy in your conversation.
So my job today will
be to keep up with you
in some ways. (laughs)
- Yeah, actually catching me
on like I don't know if I would
I don't wanna call it an off day
because I don't wanna like label you know
you're gonna love all this.
I've done so much therapy.
I'm like I don't wanna label it.
I don't wanna judge it.
I'm just gonna experience what's going on,
but it definitely feels
like an off day for me.
I feel like I'm stuck between
I'm proud of myself and I need
to do more and work harder.
So I'm in that limbo right now.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think I really
appreciate you just sharing
that honestly too because
that's just part of the journey
I think we're all on.
And too many times we're
not honest about that.
You know, when we come
on programs like this
we kind of get into our performance mode
which I imagine I know
for me is easy to do
I imagine for someone like you
that could be easy to do just
based on being an athlete.
So definitely appreciate that,
that level of candor and honesty.
- Yeah.
And I prefer to not be in like
quote unquote performance mode.
And I know what you mean you know it's
if I've had a question
asked to me 100 times
I just go on autopilot
and I give the answer
but that doesn't always
feel like my choice.
You know, it always feels like it's
up to the asker or
whoever I'm speaking with
like I don't know what
do they want from me?
And it's actually made me reflect
on how I interview people
as well on my podcast
because I'll find like
some people interview
and I know exactly what
story I want them to tell,
like I've watched the players tribune this
or ESPN that and I'm like
I want them to just reiterate
that on my show, right?
- Yeah.
- And then I think gosh,
are they then sitting there
feeling the way I do sometimes where I'm
like regurgitating a story
that I've told before.
So it's my reminder to sit
down with guests and be like,
what do you want to talk
about today? (laughs)
- Yeah. That's so important.
I think and it's a fine line to walk too
'cause like you said
I mean the fact that you
want them to tell that story,
I assume it's because you want that.
You want your audience to hear that story.
It's gonna connect with them.
But at the same time
do you want to be kind of
caring for your guests too
to kind of really be
their authentic selves
and to share in a way that
feels meaningful to them so.
- Definitely.
- Yeah, definitely a journey
that we're walking on
and figuring out as we go.
But I mean to be honest,
I feel like you've done
such a great job
with that in so many different ways.
I mean, just listening to some
of the conversations
that you've held online
and the way that your audience
engages is really reflective
of how much they appreciate
just your level of authenticity.
- Thanks. Yeah I really feel
like that's been a priority
of mine or like an
unwavering goal is I never
want my accounts to feel
preachy or like know all.
And I think there are people
who serve that purpose.
Like I don't know Tony
Robbins isn't gonna post
about having a hard day.
He's always gonna come with the like
and here's how you handle it.
And here's the way it's done
and here's the three steps to whatever.
And sometimes I'm just like,
hey it's a bad day, period.
I don't wanna fix it today.
I don't know how
and I think that's given me a lot
of flexibility in what
people expect from me
and lets me use my platforms authentically
because I don't feel pressure
to always have the answer
which is nice.
'Cause I don't always have the answer.
- Exactly.
And I think that's why people
are connecting with you
'cause they can relate in that space too
if someone's going
through that same place,
they can feel like okay,
well here is someone
that I can just listen to
and engage with through this media
and that knows kind of feel where I'm at
and really know what I'm
going through because
they're being honest about
what they're going through.
So I think there's a lot of power in that.
And then you know it gives
you a space as I'm sure
you know kind of share
the victories and the joys
and the challenges along the way and just
I think is really, really important
for all of us as a society so.
- Yeah. I love it.
Thank you.
- Now on that note I
think I also just wanna
I mentioned to you before we jumped in
just wanted to kind of
check in with you as well.
I know you mentioned already this is a
not an off day, not an on
day somewhere in between,
but I mean I'm actually
just curious because I mean
I think in so many ways
all of us as a society
we're still going through so much.
I mean, things are starting to get back
to quote unquote normal or this new normal
whatever that is.
I mean, restaurants are opening up again,
for me as an NBA fan it's nice
to see people in the stands,
you know it's a different level of energy
with the games they're going on.
Just being a college professor, you know
having students coming
back and things like that.
But then at the same time
and we'd just hit some grim statistics
because we just hit 600,000
COVID related deaths
in the US, we still have all
the challenges that are going
on around social injustice.
There's still shootings
that are happening all
over the country.
So in some ways it feels I mean
just personally
disorienting, it was like, oh
this is excitement but
there's also these challenges.
There's also personal
things we walk through.
So I just I actually just
wanted to start there
and see how you're doing
in the midst of all these mixed things
that are happening societally these days
and even in your own life.
- Yeah. It's a difficult balancing act.
I think some days I am super tuned in
to the darkness of the world
and then other days I'm not
but then the days that I'm not
I'm like I have the
privilege to not be floating
in the darkness today and to
turn it off and others don't.
And so it's tough, you know
and then at the same
time everyone you wanna
validate your own emotions
and your own experiences
but in a time like this
how can you not compare
and have perspective to who has it worse
than you or what could have
happened to your family
or your loved ones this year
that didn't or maybe it did.
So yeah, it's a lot I
think with my mental health
I like to get to the root of things.
I like to uncover
why is something triggering
for me or why am I anxious?
And I think I've struggled with accepting
that I'm not gonna have an
answer every single day.
You know, we've been through so much
that this is like a whole new
for lack of a better term
like guinea pig or like
this is an experience that
the world hasn't had before.
Like psychologists haven't
seen before, you know
we're all figuring out what's going on,
why we're not as motivated or why
something's happening to us.
And so I think today is
one of those days for me
where I'm trying not to
judge or label how I feel
but I definitely feel anxious today.
And I definitely feel like I'm running
but I'm not getting anywhere.
- Yeah.
- How do you feel?
- That makes a lot of sense.
I think I'm with you a lot of ways too.
I mean, one thing that I've
shared on this podcast before
it's just the way that the
pandemic 'cause normalize anxiety
in a way that we didn't have before
because of all the unknown
and that being kind of a root
of some of those challenges
with anxiety we can't predict
what's coming next and don't
feel like you have control.
And just the fact that we've been going
through a pandemic that we can't predict
I think has leveled the playing field.
So I think similar to
you I have tried just
in my own life to pay more attention
to what's causing those feelings.
But even for me personally
I'd say sometimes that processing is slow
and it's been slower in the pandemic.
So in some ways I would say
today it just feels mixed.
So there are things I'm
trying to be excited about
but I'm also sober at the same time,
but then I wanna kind of pace myself.
Do I wanna dig into every
single piece of news
that's out there right now
but some of the tragedies
that are happening, no.
Do I wanna totally ignore them?
No. So in some ways it's just almost kind
of choosing when I have time
to kind of engage in those
but not being oblivious
to them at the same time.
But also some of it I would
say is just giving myself kind
of grace along the way to say that, okay
things are gonna be off sometimes
I'm not gonna be able to
figure out the root cause of it
like I would normally want to,
maybe take a pause
and kind of come back to that.
So I'd say today I don't
know if I call it an on day.
I'd say it's a fine, the day is fine.
The fact that we're doing this podcast
also helps to be honest
if I'm being honest with
my listeners as well.
'Cause that's something
that I look forward to
when we're doing these
recordings and I gained so much
from just hearing our
guests like you just share
about their experiences and
really encourage others.
So it's a mixture to be completely honest.
It's a mixture of kind of
all those things altogether
but this is definitely
one of the highlights
I think that in my own way unintentionally
I'm using these podcasts to
kind of elevate my own mood
in some ways on a day-to-day basis.
And it just gives me hope
to be completely honest.
- Yeah, I connect to that too.
You know having a deep conversation
can change the trajectory
of your day, you know?
And there are certain times I sit down
and I have a conversation and like I leave
in a completely different
mood, like so inspired,
so motivated or comforted or whatnot.
And so I'm looking forward to it as well
just to be like completely present
and go wherever our conversation may.
- Yup. Yup.
I'm 100% with you on that.
And I think it really speaks
to that level of community too.
I mean, obviously community
looks very different these days
and it has in the past
and there's all these
conversations and arguments about
can you still have that community by Zoom?
Do you have to be in person
and there's valid pieces
to all that but I think
there's still space
for kind of deep authenticity
that doesn't have to
always happen in person.
I mean, people have been doing that
through phone calls, through texts.
And so it really, I think
in some ways it's given us
opportunities to really dig
into that in another way for me personally
not to get too general.
And so I've seen that
even throughout COVID
I have family that's spread
out all over the world.
So the gatherings we've been
able to have at holidays
we wouldn't have had another time,
just being able to connect
with people in ways
and family members that we
wouldn't have had before
grant is still takes a level
of us being willing to go
to that place of authenticity when we get
on these Zoom calls and things like that.
But I think there's a
tremendous opportunity there.
- Yeah. The weird thing though about Zoom
or FaceTime or whatnot
is you feel so connected
and then the minute it's
end or computer shuts
you're alone again in your
house or your apartment and that
I think is really weird.
And also there's an
element of I don't know
just sensing someone's
aura or their energy.
And I miss that, you know
it's possible to have
conversations and go deep
without that but I don't
know, awkward silences.
I weirdly miss those,
I miss feeling tension or whatnot.
And that's stuff I'm excited
for as the world opens back up.
But I think it has
certainly taught us a lot
about connection.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And I think that's a great perspective.
I mean that you're
highlighting kind of both sides
of the coin too 'cause
I definitely even since
as I've had get-togethers
outside with students, you know
over the semester it's
just a different level
of energy that comes through.
And it's almost like that just
that one hour meeting kind
of changes like you said
it's trajectory of everyone's day.
There was just a different
pep in people's step.
I know I'm sounding
like I'm 50 years old right
now, but that's okay. (laughs)
But you know, just what that did
to really change people's
attitude during the day.
Just that in-person connection.
It's funny you mentioned the awkwardness,
the silent awkwardness
'cause those pieces are
definitely there too
but even in the way those
were energizing too.
So there's a lot of learning, yeah
- Definitely.
I feel like learning so much
and there's weirdly like
obviously I don't wish that the past year
like I don't wish that
had happened to our world
but if I'm trying to find a
silver lining and like accept
that this did happen
and this is what it is
there are so many things
that I think I've learned
and ways I've grown.
And I don't know if I would
have had those realizations
or that time or those family connections
or family issues addressed
had there not been such silence,
panic and claustrophobia
at one time, you know?
So I'm definitely
leaving like the pandemic
I literally got a coffee today
without a mask for the first time.
It was so weird.
I felt like that was big for me.
I definitely feel
like there's so much I
learned throughout this time.
- Well, that's really
encouraging for me to hear too.
And I think even for our
audience, because in a lot of ways
just everything that you've
done over the last few years
you've been at such a high level
of sharing your stories
so openly and honestly,
I think people are getting a lot of that
from you both to even hear
that you're still learning
in the process I think
is just really beneficial
for people to be able to hear as well
to know that even someone like
you who's had such a journey
and has learned so much
there's always more to learn.
It's not like this is
kind a one-time thing
with that just ended in a sense.
And that's the end of the story.
- Definitely. And that's
something that I have
to remind myself of.
Like I had an instance
I gave a keynote virtually
to the University of Wisconsin
on mental health and
body image these issues.
And that's a big school for me.
Like that's a power five
conference school, you know
I am it's Wisconsin.
And then I'm so the whole few days before
and the day of like
I just had such imposter
syndrome, I was like I mean
and a whole other conversation
is giving a keynote virtually.
I mean, it's already a lose,
like no one's showing up to Zoom
prepared to be fully
engaged for 45 minutes.
Whereas they be when they
walk into an auditorium
like okay, I'll invest my emotions.
I'll open my heart.
It's so that's weird.
And then I'm not just like
presenting a math presentation.
I'm like opening up my heart
which is even harder
because I'm like, hello
is anyone on the other side of the screen?
You see people fidgeting,
turning off their cameras
is really difficult.
So that's an element.
And then I'm I have that
imposter syndrome of like
what if they don't like
what I have to say?
What if I don't touch someone?
What if I don't move them?
What if I lose sight
and then I had like a last
minute therapy session that day.
Like I happen to be able to get
squeezed in by my therapist.
And she said to me,
but isn't that what you
speak about this right now?
Like why do you feel
like you have to pretend
this isn't happening?
You know, why don't you
like open up your keynote
in your intro with like guess where I was
at one o'clock today, like therapy.
And so I, after they read my introduction
I was like, I gotta admit today
it feels really weird to hear
my intro because I cringe
at like the accomplishments
and the whatnot
because I still don't feel
like good enough that I
even did things, you know?
And then it just really
made me feel lighter
continuing with the presentation
because my big fear
that I'm not good enough
and I'm an imposter.
Well, guess what I told everyone
in the first two minutes
and I also think I did gain some respect
'cause they were like, whoa,
this is TMI from this lady.
What else does she have to say?
So I think going back
to how we even got here
in the first place is I feel very okay
in not having the answers and
I'm always trying to learn
but I definitely have to
remind the people who follow me
about all the time
because they do come to me
as if I have all the answers
or that I'm totally healthy
and done with depression
and body image issues
or there's an expectation
of like I'm always happy.
I'm always on top of my
anxiety and my sadness and my
and it's just not the case.
And so I feel like I'm
always saying back, hi
I know some stuff, but I'm
still as lost as you. (laughs)
- Yeah, I think that goes a long way.
I imagine that folks can
really resonate with that
especially when they're walking
through it at the same time.
And it's just it's just good to hear that.
Not good in the sense that
like oh, this is great
but good in the sense
that it's authentic and it
empowers other people too
just everything you're going through.
So I'm also, you know
there may be a few members of our audience
who don't know your story too.
So I'd be curious if you
could just share with them
especially along this journey
and the way that you just
even talked about the imposter syndrome.
That's definitely real
and so big at times I've
had similar situations
where I've shared my story
as a black neuroscientist
with imposter syndrome in a Zoom setting
to hundreds of virtual people I can't see.
So definitely relate
to you on that aspect.
But like with all of
that, how did you even get
to this place of wanting
to share your story?
Especially because it was already hard
and with all those challenges
or how did you move into this
space of saying, okay, well
I'm gonna take this imposter syndrome.
I'm still gonna talk about it.
What gave you that strength?
- So just to stop myself
from speaking for the next hour nonstop
I'll give you like the
elevator pitch of my story.
I essentially went to USC to
play volleyball and on paper
you know that was everything
I had worked wanted
out of high school, you
know, Pac-12, great team,
great school academics like had friends
like this is what I was supposed to do.
Like I'm a successful teenager,
but then I started to realize
that no matter how many
boxes you check off in life
that's not the answer to happiness,
fulfillment, meaning, purpose
all those important things
that we really need.
And it took me a while to learn that.
But my freshman year I
felt so much pressure.
It's like I finally made it to cloud nine
and then it was okay well,
let's survive at cloud nine.
And we were number one
team in the country.
National Player of The Year
is on the court with me,
we're in the first 22 games,
I'm adjusting to the
college academic level.
I'm always missing class.
I'm on planes every other week.
I mean, it was just a whole new lifestyle
and so much demand that
I was not prepared for.
And that I did not know how to handle.
And so as a result, I
developed performance anxiety
intertwined with some binge
eating as coping, and then going
through that for two
years, I didn't, oh, sorry.
Going for that for those
two things for one year
I didn't know what was happening to me.
You know, I was like why
am I crying before games?
Why am I so nervous to play?
Why is my heart racing?
I didn't even know performance
anxiety was a thing.
I thought people had social anxiety.
I really didn't understand the scope.
And I was like, I talk to people.
I make friends.
Like I don't have that.
So I was like, what's happening to me.
There was also that look at me
and I'm going off on my hour rant.
I'm almost done.
I'm like there's also this pressure
and this idea of what an athlete is
a D one athlete at USC, Pac-12 champions.
You know, you don't have
weakness, you get the job done.
You don't make excuses, you figure it out.
So I also felt really
insecure and not valid
in the anxiety I was facing
and the body image issues.
And then come my sophomore year
I mean, fell, hit that wall.
And that was depression for me.
And so having gone
so that was kind of how
those things manifested.
But then it was my sophomore year
when I finally was seeing a therapist
I'd really hit that place of
like, it's either continue
into the darkness which at
this point I'm terrified about
or have that conversation
and wave my white flag
and surrender what I thought
I was doing at the time.
And then in getting help
and starting to get better
and getting on meds and
start to understand, oh
this is what's going on.
This is why it happened.
This is how you can make it better.
Like you're normal, there's solutions.
There's ways to go about this.
That's when that next
element of like, whoa
well then why was I so caught off guard?
Why wasn't I aware of this?
Why didn't I know it was okay.
And then that's really
what sparked my desire
to share was truly so
that no other athlete
had to go through what I did.
You know, that we could say
something before it happened
and you know that confidence
didn't come out of nowhere.
I was journalism major.
I love storytelling.
I love being in front of cameras.
So once I understood and came to terms
with what had happened
to me and accepted it,
then the normal personality
that I had kicked in of like,
well let's talk about this,
let's bring attention to it.
So then I delivered that TED talk
which is a whole another story
but it wasn't as easy
as I just made it sound.
And then that from that point on
was really finding my voice.
- Yeah. That's great in so many ways.
I mean, it sounds like there
was an awakening in a sense
I mean it sounds like part of
that was the healthy fear too
of where things could go
and that you've just decided
you didn't want to be in that place.
- Yeah. You know, I think the thing
that I can always come back to is
my young life like as a teenager
I never understood why
people would kill themselves.
I didn't get it.
It was like but life is so great.
Why wouldn't she wanna live?
Why wouldn't you wanna be alive.
And then it was my sophomore year
I remember thinking to
myself, oh now I know.
Now I know why people don't wanna be here
and they don't wanna live.
And that was my whoa.
We are somewhere else now.
And you know, that was for me
that like awareness of
okay, I've tried to deal
with this myself and
it's only gotten worse.
And of course now I'm at
a place where like, yes
I have sympathy and so much compassion
and love for those who
are unable to keep living
but I don't feel that way anymore
which is why I'm so passionate
about like pulling
someone out of those steps
because I've been in the
depths and I'm out of them.
And so I want people to know
you can escape those feelings.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So important that realization
I think that goes a long way.
You know, obviously as we
talk about a lot of times
the fact that people are just
trying to escape the pain
because they can't figure
out how to deal with it.
So I think the fact that
you have that awareness
and can kind of meet people there.
And then also that the
fact that you're talking
about all the things that
you wish you'd been aware
of beforehand, because you just
thought things were normal.
You didn't know necessarily
what was going on at a time.
And so the fact
that you're kind of empowering others
to tackle things head-on early
on I think is so important.
I'm curious even if you know
if you're willing to elaborate more just
in terms of 'cause you
know student athletes
who may be listening in like what is
how do you find that line
between having a high level
of performance and expectation
but then knowing when to pull back
because as I've heard you talk
about lots of times, you know
as an athlete there is that fine line of
there is someone else
that's ready to replace you
if you kind of slip
in your performance or
if there's that window.
So I mean, that's to me
that doesn't sound like
an easy decision to make
and I'd expect that extends
beyond sports as well.
I mean, people who are in
tense work environments,
tense academic settings
even to take it a scope a
little bit for them thinking
about some of the things
we've talked about
at this podcast in terms
of minorities who are
in situations where they're the only one
there's this huge weight
to kind of represent kind
of a bigger culture than yourself
and that all those tensions
I'm just curious, you know
in your own experience
how do you suggest that
people kind of figure out
that line about when to seek help?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I have a few things I'll share on that.
I will preface this by saying I'll speak
from the perspective of a
competitive student athlete
because that's my experience
and I never wanna act
like I understood even the surface
of the struggles, you know minority
or someone without white
privilege might be experiencing.
So recognize that.
And don't wanna even act
like I could elaborate on
answering that question,
but to the experiences
of like a high-performing student athlete
or high-performing academic student
what I would say is, you know
the way that sports culture
teaches you to work hard
and like the way they
communicate work ethic
is it's the grind.
It's you always go one more,
you always push harder.
You do the best don't rest.
You know, unless this is one
of the most absurd quotes
that used to motivate me,
unless you puke, faint or die, keep going.
I mean, that is something
that I had on my locker
like that is something athletes use.
And it's also praised
by like the G.O.A.T.S
which I can also get into later
because Kobe Bryan actually has expressed
different thoughts on this.
You know, things get misconstrued.
But first thing I'd say is
the way that it's communicated
to us is go, go, go, go, go, never stop.
And any excuses or pull back is weakness.
So that's the first problem is
like we're being taught the wrong thing.
It's an impossible standard.
It doesn't work.
The second piece that
I'd actually be curious
your thoughts on this.
And I learned this
from one of my favorite
sports psychologists,
Dr. Michael Gervais,
but there's a difference
between mental health
and mental toughness.
And the line often gets very blurry.
And the difference is not communicated
to athletes nor to coaches.
Coaches most of the time are the ones
who asked this question
because they don't understand like
how do I know when my player is depressed
or when he's just not trying,
or she's just not doing this.
So mental health is obviously
like your general state of
mind, your general wellbeing.
Like let's imagine that
as the base, if you think
of physical health ironically
it's easy to understand
you know, someone physically healthy.
Then mental toughness is
something that can be trained.
It's a skill, it's with reps,
with time with putting yourself
in the trenches with overcoming adversity
time and time again you
get tougher mentally.
However, the way they relate
to like peak performance
and being an elite athlete
or an elite performer in any capacity
is mental health is the foundation.
And then mental toughness is
the bridge to peak performance,
sustainable peak performance.
So athletes have to
understand is am I working
at my base or am I building
my bridge right now?
And that's something that I
think each person has to learn
for themselves.
And they have to be
willing to identify that.
To give an example my freshman
year I started and I played
but I wasn't in the position I wanted.
I was like in a second string role
but not the first string role.
And I remember similar to that mentality
I was like okay, when she's
in the gym I'm in the gym.
If she's passing, I'm passing.
If she goes, I go, like,
I will outwork you.
And as a result, all of my
choices and actions were based
on outworking her not actually focusing on
what was best for me.
And so I got anxious, I overworked myself.
I wasn't listening to my body,
listening to my training,
then come my senior year
I'm in that first string position.
I've done all this work and
what do you know that girl
behind me she's staying extra.
She's doing this and that.
And I don't know if it
was motivated by me.
She could have just been doing it.
But I felt that in me, oh my gosh,
you know my backup is doing these things.
Should I stay?
And I was like, you know what, no
I gave my all for three hours.
I feel like I had a good practice.
And I think it's more beneficial
for me to call it a day,
grab my water shower
and go eat dinner with my
roommate because I put my work in
I feel good about that.
You know, it has to be based on you.
And another thing that comes
to mind and you mentioned this
in the question was this idea
of like holding back and one
of my favorite quotes from
Kobe Bryant's recent novel
"Geese Are Never Swans"
is it takes more strength to hold back
than it does to push.
The easy thing is to go one.
Yeah. The easy thing is to go one more
to do what coach says.
The easy thing is to buy in.
The harder thing is to
speak up for yourself.
The harder thing is to say,
I don't have this in me.
I'm working at Efuel and I've
been there for two days now.
I need to rest.
I need recovery.
So lots of points there in an answer
to your question, I would
invite everyone to explore.
Are you working with your mental health?
Is this an issue of mental toughness?
And can you play with that
and use your experiences to help guide you
to when you're making the right call?
- Yeah, I think that's so helpful.
I mean, you cover a lot of ground there.
I think it's all all great.
Especially that distinction
between the toughness
versus a mental health.
I mean, to expand that a little bit,
I mean that's something
I think we talk a lot
about within the field.
And so with me as a basic
neuroscientist and you
might have some clinical
shadowing that I've done as well.
And one of the things that we often talk
about is just if that
baseline has shifted.
And you mentioned that
when you're were talking
about your journey as
well, so are there days
or weeks on end where people are different
than they were before,
are they is their mood kind of shifted
for long periods of time
even on the playing field,
on the court, et cetera
like has that baseline really
just adjusted completely
where there's not as much motivation
to get up each day to kind of stay
on the grind versus is it a
matter of mental toughness
which is kind of more
of an acute or short-term
situational type of thing.
So I think it's really
helpful how I've kind of
highlighted those pieces as well
because I think that's part
of the nuance and really
if people can sense that
the baseline has shifted
like you talked about, that's
a whole nother scenario
then talking about the mental
toughness of each situation.
And like you said
you can kind of build and
practice that mental toughness.
So I know that's a framework
that people have used as well,
but just in terms of when we're talking
to just general population
that's often something that
we mentioned, just looking
for those differences and
kind of overall demeanor
and mood or a shift from kind
of what looks to be people's
normal mode beforehand.
- Yeah. And I'm curious
your thoughts on this
because it's something
I've been thinking about
I don't know, by how like
a concrete take on it
but it's great that anxiety, depression
all these things are being normalized.
However, sometimes I wonder
if someone experiences nervousness
and says I have anxiety
or experiences sadness
and says I'm depressed.
And it's tough because if
someone says they're anxious
or depressed, you don't
wanna question that,
you wanna validate that
and take their word for it.
That's so important.
However, are we getting to sensitize
to what like the actual
mental illness are and the
what the concrete diagnosable
mental health issues are?
And as a result are some of
the people who are just nervous
or just sad kind of maybe
giving up too soon on the fact
that they could do some work there
to get back to a place they wanna be.
I almost think people are so focused
on being happy all the time at
the minute and emotion comes
that's not happiness.
We wanna label it as something
that maybe it's not yet.
And I know that that's
like controversial to say.
I just think it's an important component.
- Yeah, I think it's a
really good question.
I'll be a little bit speculative
in that sense as well
but I think you're onto something as well.
So I mean, from a clinical standpoint
whenever people are in
the clinical situation
with clinical anxiety, you know
generalized anxiety disorder
or depression kind of one
of the hallmarks within therapy
is not to avoid the anxiety
because that just lets it sit.
So there's lots of ways that psychologists
kind of walk people
through that to kind of
you can do exposure theory to kind of walk
up to things over time
and kind of deal with it.
But the reason I bring that
up it's I think it ties in
to what you're mentioning as
well when people are talking
about times of being
anxious or feeling sad.
And so there's a line there
and this is a specular part.
There's a line to walk where
you don't want people who are
feeling that to just avoid it
because that in itself is not
necessarily healthy because
in some ways, you know
some aspects of anxiety are good for us.
It kind of helps us geer up.
So you know from a classroom
setting and people often talk
about if you're getting
a little bit anxious
about a test that's probably good.
It would probably encourage you to study
and not just wing it.
So there's a ramping up.
It kind of forcing you
to take that seriously.
Or if someone's giving a talk
in front of 100,000 people,
there's probably gonna be some anxiety
but that's not necessarily bad.
It can kind of help them
elevate their performance.
So you know that can come in
with sports environments as well.
But I do think there is a line to walk.
And I don't know if I have a
clear answer for you in terms
of making sure that people
are empowered to still move
through those things.
So like you said you have to validate it.
You don't want to be dismissive of it
because you don't know the
level of depth that it is,
but at the same time
you don't want people to
be and maybe this is where
you're going with your question
to be hampered by that.
- Yeah.
Sometimes I think mental
health issues or mental illness
or eating disorders can become glamorized.
And you see people wanting
to have that issue.
And I don't know, like
I said I don't have a
it's something I've noticed
and I don't have like a take on it.
I just think it's worth thinking
about because it's important
to the conversation.
- I agree.
And I think that comes down
to some of the awareness
that you talked about too
so that people have a clear
sense of what's just normal
isn't the best word to use
but what's a normal level of anxiety
to expect in this situation
versus what is something
that's really much more severe.
And so one example I've painted some times
as in terms of a worry versus anxiety.
Worry is a little bit more kind
of acute in that situation.
So if someone's worried about a test
it'll kind of be localized
to that experience.
If they're worried about their performance
with their boss will be localized
to that specific
interaction with their boss
when they get some more anxiety
becomes much more generalizable.
So every time they walk
into a classroom setting
if they start to feel any of
those like physical sensations
they're associated with
anxiety or overwhelmed
that's kind of more of a
something that might touch on
some of those clinical pieces.
So it kind of depends
on the expansion of it.
And so I think in some ways
it can be helpful, you know
when people are bringing
the app to kind of
if people are willing
to dive in a little bit
and talk through what
that experience is like
and I think that can kind
of help people distinguish.
And again, it kind of depends
on how long it's lasting
and how much different from
the norm, but granted I mean
I'm saying all that, but there
is also there are challenges
with the way that we
diagnose things as well.
So I have to know, I have to put that
and we've talked about that
across cultures as well.
How are those even designed
and are they applied
to one group versus do
they take into account
what different people experiences
in different cultures?
- So true.
And like now to flip the
switch and maybe be the people
I'm talking about is with eating disorders
there's such a specific clinical threshold
that you need to like meet
to have that diagnosis.
And so there's that that's
one example specific example.
And then there's obviously
something sad I've been
learning is like not every
professional licensed
professional is necessarily on their game,
like necessarily knows
what you're talking about
which is crazy.
Like how can someone be
a licensed mental health
professional and not be like,
not be not necessarily good
at what they're doing
but miss things or
over-diagnosis, whatnot.
So you're right.
There's totally a flaw in the system there
as well as people might not
be getting the diagnosis
that they need or that's right for them.
And I certainly felt that
way with my eating disorder
because I know I had a
binge eating disorder.
I would not call what
happened to me less than that.
But if I look up the wrong
site or the wrong list
that there's like one thing I don't meet,
and of course I had one of our
dieticians at USC, you know
when we met she was the
one that like diagnosed
and confirmed this for me
but I always still felt a
little insecure about it
but I've come into my own of like, no
I know this is what was wrong with me.
And so then once again,
there's that other side of
the conversation is people
know what they're going
through and it's always
hard to get maybe an external
person to validate that
and fully understand
what their needs may be.
- Yeah. I think that's really important.
And I think one thing that
can be helpful there, well
a couple of things actually,
I mean you're right
unfortunately in the
sense that not everyone
is on their A game when it comes
to just dealing with mental health.
And so there unfortunately
has to be some level
of discernment on people
who are looking for help
which is unfortunate
'cause it's backwards.
It shouldn't be that way, but
sometimes it might mean going
through two or three people
until you find the right match.
And again, just knowing people, you know
just figuring out if people
are doing things appropriately
that's a lot of, and again, this is a lot
of unnecessary weight on
the person who is looking
that we often say is
like are people actually
willing to listen to your
story when you come in
because you are the expert on your life.
And you're sharing that with
someone, are they listening
to your story and trying to
figure out where you're at?
Or are they just taking a specific thing
and kind of dumping that on
you, a specific diagnosis,
specific framework and dumping
that on you, which again
gets to the thing that
you talked about before
of are they aware or
equipped to really deal
with the binge eating
disorder if it's there.
And we talked about that again.
I know I keep kind of harping back
to the theme of the podcast
but we've talked a lot
about just cultural competency too.
If people are able to think
about where different people come from
I think it's extends
even the things athletes
may be going through people
from different cultures and
listening to those stories
or kind of just dumping a
specific diagnosis on people.
So I think when there
are those who kind of
have that balance of their
expertise and listening
to where people are coming from
I think it goes a long way.
- Yeah.
That's all fascinating.
- Are there ways that
'cause there's I mean
there's so many good things
that we're pulling out here.
This would probably be a
three-hour conversation
but are there ways that
you've tried to even
incorporate some of these
concepts in your talks or online
and your podcasts on YouTube
to really empower people?
'Cause I mean, the questions
that you're wrestling through
the questions that we're talking through
I think people can clearly tell
from the conversation even we
don't have all the answers.
So how do you take that
and try to help other people even get
to a place of knowing where to start?
- I think I've had to get clear
on what my purpose is and
what value I can bring
and you know, I'm not a psychologist.
And so I'm not gonna be
hosting one-on-one sessions
with athletes acting
like I can solve their
problems because I can't.
But I think what my value
add is is de-stigmatizing
the issue for people who are in similar
highly touted roles, position
like I was.
So I think there's that element.
I think there's normalizing
the many concerns
and challenges and
insecurities and struggles
that people in those
situations are facing as well.
I think it's also relating
and being able to speak
on that level of like,
I'm a teammate or I am
like a friend, oftentimes
when I come in to speak
there's just a totally
different connection
because I it's almost like street credit.
It's like I've been in
their shoes exactly.
Like I know what they're going through
where sometimes when
someone tries to relate
to you and they don't get it,
it's just I often have
we'll have literally
like the sports psychologist
at the school be like, gosh
like they're listening to you
but say the same thing I've
said, but only because you're
like the same age as
them and you played it
as in like you get it
because when it's coming
from an adult or someone
who's not close to.
So I think that's also something
unique is it's one thing
for the for even, I mean
the school is lucky to have
an athletic director address mental health
but if someone in that
position addresses it
it's still won't hit the same as a peer.
And I consider myself a peer
and I think that's one of my super powers.
And in that sense for this conversation.
- Yeah. I agree with you on that.
Well, what are some of the
pieces that you try because even
as you're talking to other
student athletes or coaches
are there specific tips that you have
for folks in terms of
like what to look out for?
Because one of the things
I've often wondered, you know
as you were going through everything
did you do you think your teammates
and friends do they notice anything,
what are the things
that they could've said
that would've been helpful?
And if so are the things we
try and pass along to others?
- Yeah. You know, I would say talking
so what if I'm sharing my story
or speaking or giving
takeaways or whatever it is.
I think most of the time with athletes
I like them to know that
their journey and their trajectory
while the details might
be different than mine
like, hey, I get it.
And this is how it happened
to me and how it might've happened to you.
And you are not alone in that.
And I think with coaches, it's more
this is the experience, or this is how
like the epitome of your
number one ideal recruit
like the epitome of that
for you, how they went
off the rails or how they
didn't become successful
or how they struggled
or suffered in some way.
Because I like to think when
I walked on USC's campus
I was everything a coach
would want, not from like
and I'm not speaking about talent.
I'm speaking about like coachability.
I was eager to be there.
I was a good teammate.
I was energetic.
I was positive.
I was enthusiastic.
Like all the intangibles
you would want in a player
like I really would back myself up
and I walked onto campus with those.
How does that athlete become depressed?
How does that athlete become anxious
and not want to play anymore?
And so that's the journey
I try to take those
coaches on because they sit
in their office and they
don't know how that happened.
Or they say like we know
you guys are stressed
but no one's actually really said, yeah.
And like this is why we have the 6:00 a.m.
This 7:00 a.m. that 9:00 a.m.
And then I get home at seven.
I got to watch film.
And then at 6:00 p.m. again,
like no one's really, you know
that's the other thing from
the coach's perspective
is I get to say what the
player's afraid to say.
And that's the value add there is like
your players are thinking
this and I don't care.
You can't bench me.
So I'm gonna explain
what's going on. (laughs)
- Yeah. I think that's so powerful.
I mean, you're giving that voice
and I think that goes such a long way.
And it's actually wraps back
into the point you made earlier too
about just everything with COVID.
I feel like, and I could be wrong
but there is at least from a
coaching standpoint it seems
like there has been a little
bit more awareness of that.
And again, I'm talking
from the outside as a non-college athlete
but just things I've seen
even remember you know
I'm a duke grad and think
about coach K giving the team a couple
of weeks off instead of playing games
because he said he was
concerned for his players
mental health and just
giving them a space.
So grant this is from the outside
but I don't ever remember hearing any
of those conversations beforehand.
Maybe more so has kind
of been the backlash.
So I think it's great that you're there
in a way infiltrating
is not the right word
but in a sense I mean,
you're on the ground
having those conversations,
making sure it gets heard
and hopefully in a way that penetrates
that people are able to kind
of receive and incorporate.
- Right. And I think that's
talking about, you know
the benefits from what's
happened is the awareness
and the inability to deny the legitimacy
of mental health issue
for so many different groups of people.
So it's I think that's been a
one of the positives.
It's also hard to say
of all of this is like
you can't ignore mental health anymore.
You know, the crisis is real.
It was real, it's even worse now.
And we can't just ignore it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think that's so important.
Hopefully that feels encouraging
and validating the work
that you've been doing
for years already.
I mean, I know that what
you're doing is so impactful
for so many people and just even some
of the videos that you've put online
the ways that people have
responded to your work
I know it goes a long way
and I assume it's spreading
too like each person
that you touch is able to kind of share
that with others around them as well.
So definitely appreciate
the work that you're doing.
I feel like a time went really quickly.
We could probably go on for quite a while.
Any last words of advice or
wisdom that you want to share
with the audience in terms
of just the general audience
and student athletes in particular?
- Yeah. Well, first of
all thanks for having me.
I agree it flew by was
great speaking with you.
I just love to encourage
any student athletes who are maybe looking
for that community or looking
for a place to have their story heard
or for support can definitely
check out the Hidden Opponent
which is the nonprofit I founded.
We have a really cool
private Facebook group
with over 1,000 athletes.
Cool, free events, you know
just a place where if you wanna connect
with other athletes who are
having these conversations
and feel supported to
definitely check that out.
And that's just thehiddenopponent.com
or The Hidden Opponent on Instagram.
- Excellent.
Well, definitely appreciate
you sharing that.
And again, appreciate the
work that you're doing
to really help so many folks and empower
and help people kind of
be whole in that sense
and really make sure that mental
health is at the forefront.
And of course, thanks for
jumping on the Addy Hour.
Appreciate having you here.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)